today I did things that I never thought
possible I can do the impossible
something new because I'm just very Alan
but you're as a flash you been so busy
running between alternate realities
various protecting your world and our
world needs a flash right about now as
fast John get over it never
zooms still up there carry the weight of
the world on your shoulders take control
of it or it would eat at you it just is
nothing left the flash has gone rogue
expose him as a fraud what happened you
unearth to doubt he's here it's all
right this is far from
the monster is our beautiful
berry - so a berry from yesterday was
not you zoom has my daughter and our
berry we need to find his lair lair he's
a bad guy I'm calling it a lair tell us
where you are you serious
we're going up there I'm wearing
wingtips here um I don't have much tread
hey youtubers is Charlie so you guys may
have seen the new flash footage this
morning it's actually it's not just from
next week's episode because King shark
isn't in next week's episode
it's from the next couple of episodes
there's a whole bunch of stuff going on
in this clip but the big thing is that
it looks like zoom is ripping his mask
off in next week's episode the way they
edited that first clip is a little
confusing if you assume it's from next
week's episode because you're like hey
what's king shark and Diggle doing there
they're not supposed to be there for a
couple more weeks but when you put it
into context with the second part of the
clip with Caitlin snow out in the woods
everybody trying to find bury where
zooms lair is it looks like it's on Lian
Yu but that's because they film
everything in the vancouver woods and it
seems like next week's episode based on
the pictures they posted they're going
to reveal who's in that iron mask and I
really do like the idea that it is zooms
doppelganger from earth one it's gonna
be like this big WTF oh my god it's the
person that everybody's suspected but
isn't it funny when you think about even
if it is zooms doppelganger why would
soon put an iron mask on them to prevent
them from talking the Morse code to the
Morse code from the end of the episode
was just zoom is coming that's what he
was banging on the glass zoom is coming
sister perceive zoom rushing up to the
cage at the end that's why the title of
this first trailer is zoom is coming I
really I combined two trailers here one
is the episode 14 trailer one is the
zoom is coming trailer and it's meant to
imply the rest of the season as in zoom
is coming for all of you all the people
you love coming for your speed just
broad spectrum terror coming to haunt
you man or woman in the iron mask oh who
the hell is that that's the important
question it looks like an older person
I've seen a lot of people wonder if it's
wali because the lighting is so shitty
in there and the person is so dirty it's
hard to get a proper skin tone off of
them the biggest complaint I have about
the flash season 2 is the fact that
earth 2 is sepia tone this is the TV
dummy explainer they make it sepia tone
so that you don't get confused as to
which earth you're on now normally you'd
expect people to be able to follow this
but you have a lot of TV dummies out
there that just have no idea what's
going on so earth 2 has this sepia tone
cast to it that makes it look like they
forgot to color correct it but whatever
man in the iron mask I definitely agree
that it's either Henry Allen or Wally I
really liked the idea of Wally because
people think that it's a smaller person
in John Wesley Shipp is much taller much
bulkier much bigger muscles he could
have just been covered in axle grease
when zoom came to steal them if it is
Wally and I really like the idea that
zoom is Wally there's still a number of
possibilities
I just feel thumb Attica Lee the
evidence that they've given us the types
of moments we've seen from Wally's
character his speech about trying to get
back to that happy place and the idea of
Daniel West in the comics trying to get
back to his happy place just really sync
up I really I really do feel like the
flash season 2 is all about fixing
irises family season 1 was all about
berry fixing his family getting his dad
out of prison trying to save his mother
but from Barry's perspective season 2 is
all about finding happiness in spite of
the challenge that the reverse-flash
gave him like no matter how much you win
you will never be happy and that's what
Barry is fighting he's trying to find
happiness so at the beginning of the
season you could have said that an evil
version of Barry was oom but now that
they've confirmed that that is not the
case I think that Wally's character is
much closer to that yeah it would be bad
freakin ass to let John Wesley Shipp be
the big bad for season 2 TV but I really
do feel like season 2 of the flash right
now is more about Wally in the
relationships and his family than anyone
else it's just that we haven't met him
to the last couple of episodes
what about zoom pulling the mask off
though does that mean we'll actually
learn who it is what I'm thinking is is
that when he pulls that mask off because
if you look at the clause that he has
for hands his face is going to be very
different from what his doppelganger
looks like as if the Speed Force has
twisted him zooms one of those
characters that's been twisted into a
monster inside like you know
psychologically so now it's manifesting
physically they are literally looking
like a monster I be kind of bummed out
if he looks totally normal underneath
that suit rest of the trailer though
there's a whole bunch of awesome stuff
let's start with king shark so king
sharks episode is actually a Diggle Lyla
crossover they're coming to the flash
it's gonna be at Argus based episode
king sharks supposed to escape from
Argus they have to chase them down I
know a lot of people are wondering who
this girl is here
this is trajectory our first confirmed
female speedster she will actually have
speed powers I don't know if they'll be
based on the Speed Force if it'll be a
velocity 9 explainer that's a whole
other story velocity and I want to talk
about that in a second for the rest of
the season but this is trajectory if you
didn't read the comics she's from the 52
Lex Luthor everyman project it was
during the 52 series not the new 52
completely different whose something
waged around Final Crisis so
happened a long time ago the twist is
she wasn't able to slow down without
taking a drug so think of it as the
opposite of what's happening in a jay
garrick right now if the velocity seven
that he took only lasted for a little
while
think of someone who's stuck moving at
SuperSpeed has to take a drug to slow
down so they can interact with everyone
else
that's the comics I don't know what
they're gonna change about that for the
TV show they might make it a little
simpler and just weave it in with the
velocity-9 plot and the really cool
thing there's a producer's teased about
velocity-9
is that it'll be really big part of
Jesse quick and Wally West's storyline
making me think that they will get speed
force powers by the end of the season so
just one more thing to get really pumped
about I know we see Jay Garrick moving
at SuperSpeed so I'm hoping to see
velocity eight in next week's episode
maybe velocity 9 by episode 17 it almost
forgot iris West at the paper there's a
new boss there's supposed to be some
chemistry between them he wants to go
after the flash thinks he's a criminal
iris has to defend Barry from the inside
without letting everyone know that she's
part of team flash think Peter Parker
working for Jay jonah Jameson who's
always trying to use the paper to
badmouth spider-man I like the idea that
the flash has quote-unquote gone rogue
so let me know what you guys think of
the trailer in speaking of trailers they
just confirmed the Game of Thrones was
gonna drop its season 6 trailer on
Sunday so I'll totally do a video for
that there's a new episode of Walking
Dead so a bunch of stuff happening this
weekend and I still have to make a
spoiler e Deadpool video with Easter
eggs so that'll be coming to and I am
still doing a legends of tomorrow
episode 4 video super awesome stuff
happening in the next couple of days
while you wait for my next video to post
you can click here for the Batman V
Superman trailer I just posted and you
can click here from my non-spoilery
Deadpool review thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight